What was the reasoning behind this call into an investigation?
You know, I have followed the coverage of this project, and I hadn't followed it closely
as it was being awarded.
To listen to the facts, you have a total bait and switch.
This was advertised for bid at $10 million in subsidies.
Now we're over 80, and you're building low income housing units and mixed income housing
units to the tune of $600,000, $610,000 apiece in subsidy alone.
This seems like a radical waste of money, and this is a sought after piece of property.
If the circumstances as they are today had been advertised, I think you would have had
a line of local developers that would have use their imagination and bid on a great project.
Instead, we have an out-of-town firm that's won this, and they have been showered with
public subsidies between a 30-year pilot, a $30 million in federal tax credits that
are supposed to be geared towards low income housing, as well as just a pile of state money
as well.
If a project needs this to be that viable, maybe it's not all that's cracked up to be
in the first place.
So I think the only way, after listening to business leaders, but also just the investigative
coverage between all the different local media, it looks like it's very clear that the state
violated its own policies on procurement.
And I asked the question of the inspector general of the Department of Housing and Urban
Development to review this.
Is this an appropriate use of federal tax credits?
These are a finite supply.
There's not enough for every project.
And yes, this is a large, high-profile deal downtown.
But these projects are for everyone and for every district, and there's a lot of places
throughout Western Europe and the southern tier where we have just as big of a housing
need and those low-income tax credits, are they best used on something of this grand
stature?
It doesn't pass the smell test to them.
You think of that plot of land on the waterfront, part of this effort to bring the waterfront
to be this economic force, and then you hear they get 30 years of a tax break.
How's that helping Western New York?
How's that helping Buffalo to not pumping money back into the economy?
The idea that we're going to be building low-income housing to the tune of almost a million dollars
a unit is a staggering sum of money.
Think of the home you can build for a million dollars, let alone an apartment unit.
This just doesn't pass the smell test as to be the best efficient use of a finite supply
of federal tax credits that are available for low-income housing.
And I understand you want the city to be affordable for everybody, but there seems to be a lot
of better ways that you could address housing concerns in the city and all of the surrounding
communities, rather than just create one high-profile project that sucks up all of
the tax dollars.
Yeah, when you talk about these tax credits, what are the meaning of them and how are they
distributed between districts?
The state has large input on this, and it's certain amounts of these tax credits made
available to them, and the state has decided that this, when it was advertised for bid
at a $10 million subsidy, which there's sticker shock when you say $10 million in tax credits.
When you say that now you're going to get 30 in federal and 50 in state, now you're
just in an exorbitant amount of tax revenue that is going in to build these housing units
with very little retail, and it strikes me that they should really be looking for more
destinations to create a lot more commerce downtown.
That would be the goal, and it sounded like that was the goal in the initial proposal.
I mean, have you ever seen a project that took this drastic of a move?
I mean, originally it was going to be 75% market rate, now it's 75% affordable housing.
Have you ever seen something like that before?
Well, because it's gained the programs to make it viable, and that's the unfortunate
part of a lot of the gimmickry that is available to developers, that it's clear that they came
back and said, the numbers don't work, you've got to recalculate.
But if they're going to recalculate and they're going to put 80 million bucks up of hoodies
from the taxpayers, and let's face it, folks, it's your money, they should let everybody
reinvent the thing.
Why is this going to an out-of-town developer from Philadelphia?
No one can seem to answer that, and at $10 million, it may not have been as attractive.
But something tells me there'd be a lot of interested parties for a lot less than $80
million in taxpayer giveaways.
So I'm not accusing anyone of any crime.
I've asked the Inspector General of the Department of Housing and Urban Development to determine
if the law was followed, and if this is an appropriate and efficient use of these tax
credits.
And those are the questions that need to be answered, is should the federal government
be a partner in this the way it was executed, or should it be re-bid from the beginning?
Now, obviously, your goal is to make sure, like you said, that the rules are being followed
and these credits are being where they need to go, and obviously you want credits for
your district, but are you surprised you're the only elected official who's actually responding
to the complaints of business leaders in the city of Buffalo?
Perhaps it's because I don't represent the city proper.
I mean, let's face it, business leaders, they get a lot of pressure from people in power
to not ask questions.
I don't have to worry about the leaders of the city, but I am a member of the House Oversight
Committee.
I have oversight over the entire federal government in that respect.
We can ask these questions, and this deserves just a little more scrutiny before we start
writing blank checks for, you know, giant giveaways.
And, you know, there's a lot of business leaders that have come forward and said, this isn't
on the up and up.
And I think there's been some excellent reporting that I've watched and read and listened to
that have laid these facts out.
They're very inconvenient.
I haven't accused any politician of doing anything wrong here, but this is a sour deal.
And if you're offering $80 million for a subsidy on a project like this, then they should re-bid
the whole thing.
It's up to the Inspector General to take some action and to take a look at whether or not
the state actually filed its own procurement laws, which is, I think, the most troubling
part that I've seen is that the state completely violates policies from the way I understand
the law.
I don't represent myself as an attorney, but if they violated their process, they should
restart their process.
Absolutely.
No pushback on that.
I have to say, Congressman, I am surprised that there aren't members of city government
or even at the state level pushing back on this because I just don't see it in the best
interest of what they're trying to do on that plot of land.
For me, that's the biggest thing.
This is waterfront.
We've heard about making the best of the north odd block.
This isn't what they were sold.
And usually, if I'm given something that I wasn't sold, I take it for a return and start
from point A.
I think there's just a certain desperation to get something going.
And we shouldn't just settle for something when it's a raw meal for the taxpayers.
You have the opportunity to start from scratch, reopen the conversation, invite anyone to
come forward with a great business proposal.
I mean, what is a great destination that might look at downtown Buffalo?
You don't have many parcels like that.
And to use that for what is looking more and more like just to subsidize the term I
keep reading is low and mixed income, I do agree there is an affordability crisis.
But people that are trying to get a solution to the affordability crisis don't necessarily
expect luxury apartment buildings in the core of downtown.